طلب غريب للمعلمات في مدرسه خاصه في
الاردن الطلب اشعل الجدل بسرعه واثرها
مواجهه وانتقادات واسعه بالفعل ببساطه
المدرسه طلبت من المعلمات وبشكل رسمي طلبت
منهن تنسيق الحمل ليتم الانجاب خلال
العطله الصيفيه التي تستمر لمده ثلاثه
اشهر وزاره التربيه والتعليم الاردنيه
علقت فورا على هذا الطلب
وحسمت الامر بشكل رسمي الطلب مرفوض جمله
وتفصيلا بحسب الوزاره التصرف فردي ولا
يعبر ابدا عن سياسه الاردن
[موسيقى]
احنا سالنا الناس في الاردن مدرسه تمنع
حمل المعلمات وتطلب الانجاب في فصل للصيف
ما رايكم خلينا نعمل
طبعا انا ضد هذا الموضوع ما بصير لانه من
حقها انها تحمل زيها زي اي ام عامله هذا
الاشي ما بيمنحها طبعا
وهذا الشيء طبعا بايد رب العالمين انا ضد
هذا الشيء لانه هذا كله باذن رب العالمين
طبعا
لانه هاي كمان حريه شخصيه اكيد يعني ايش
الواحد مثلا يحددوا له مثلا لازم ينجب او
لا اكيد لا ضد طبعا هذا الشيء مش مش لازم
يكون لانه الست من حقها انها تحمل وتخلف
وتنجب اطفال وطبعا هذا القرار لازم انه
يلتغى ومن الوزاره ومن المدرسه ومن
الاهالي لازم يتعاون كل الغاء هذا القرار
اكيد هذا الكلام
الامر باذن رب العالمين واحنا اللي بنشجع
على الانجاب واحنا مع الانجاب ورب
العالمين ما يحرمهم من بيت اي مخلوق هذا
الاشياء طبعا ويعني
اتوقع ويعني مش عارف شو بدي احكي لهم يعني
لازم تتعاقب هذه المدرسه
طيب يلا اما الينا من عمان نقيب المدارس
الخاصه منظر الصوراني وكذالك الناطق باسم
وزاره التربيه احمد المعازفه للحديث حول
هذا الموضوع ليبدا اولا مع السيد احمد
المعاسفه لاسالك اولا لماذا تم رفض هذا
الطلب رغم انها مدارس خاصه ولها يعني
متطلباتها وعدد مدرسينها ليش تم رفض هذا
الطلب بانه لا والله لا يجب تنظيم عمليه
الحمل والولاده بالنسبه للمدرسات او
المعلمات
[موسيقى]
فردي غير مقبول لنا في وزاره التربيه
والتعليم وغير مقبول في جميع الاعراف
التربويه في جميع الدول الاستاذ احمد
يعني تراجعت عن هذا القرار او هذا الطلب
من المعلمات هذا ما نفهم منك
نعم نعم سيدتي ارسلت بيان تعتذر فيه عن
هذا الامر واعتبرت ما جاء في الكتاب لاغيا
وسوف تحقق في الامر لتقف على حيثيات هذا
الامر طيب خليني اذهب لاستاذ منذر
الصولاني استاذ منذر هل يعقل مثل هذا
الطلب حتى وانت راجعت عنه المدرسه وربما
حسم الجدل فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه ولكن
يعني مفهوم بانه هناك مشكله فيما يتعلق
باجازات الوضع بالنسبه للمعلمات خصوصا اذا
كان كلهم يعني كان مفيدات الوقت راح يصير
في مشكله حقيقيه في المدرسه ولكن هل يعقل
ان يطلب من المعلمات مثل هذا الطلب الذي
يعني التدخل سافر في حياتهم الشخصيه
بطريقه او باخرى
تفضل استاذ منذر صباح الخير اولا صباح
النور صباح الخير اولا
اولا هو تصرف فردي
وسبق لاحدى المدارس الخاصه منذ خمس سنوات
ان اثارت هذا الموضوع بمنع الحمل في لدى
بعض المعلمات
هذا القرار اللي صدر عن اداره المدرسه
مخالف للتشريعات والانظمه وتحديدا انظمه
وقوانين وزاره العمل الذي التي حدثت
العلاقه ما بين اداره المدرسه او اي قطعه
خاص والعاملين فيهم لذلك احنا من وجهه
نظرنا كنقابه نرفض هذا القرار وهو حقيقه
ادخلنا في يعني في نقاش يجب الا يكون يبدو
المدرسه لم تدرس ابعاد هذا القرار وهو لا
يخدمها اصلا يعني لا يخدم مصلحه المدرسه
خاصه لكن الموضوع له شك الموضوع الموضوع
له الشقي الشق الاول الشق الاول انه هذا
ينحصر تقريبا في يعني بعض المدارس الخاص
بعض حاله فرديه لكن المدارس الخاصه اللي
هي لديها معلمات ذات تخصصات يعني زي
العربي والانجليزي والرياضيات والعلوم
بتكون حريصه الا يكون هنالك انقطاع في
الدراسه عن الطلبه كان الطلبه تعودوا على
هذه المعلمه لذلك تلجا هذه المدرسه او بعض
المدارس حقيقته حاله او حالتين حصل خلال
عشر سنوات الماضيه فتلجا الى اتخاذ مثل
هذا القرار اللي غير مدروس لانه اداره
المدرسه لم تطلع اصلا على التعليمات
والتشريعات التي تحدد العلاقه لذلك تصرفت
وهذا تصرف انا اعتبره خاطئ وغير مبرر
ولا ولا داعي لاثاره منذر مشكله خليني بس
اسالك اليوم المدارس الخاصه لديها طريقه
في التعليم كما ذكرت ولكن ايضا انه اليس
من حق يعني مجلس اداره هذه المدرسه انه
يطلب من المدرسات انه والله يا جماعه
نظموا لانه اذا هي اخذت اجازه الوضع فراح
المنهج طار على على الطلبه
واربعه خمس مدرسات انتهى
الكورس الدراسي او
اخي الكريم اخي الكريم ما في ضرر على
المدرسه ما في ضرر على المدرسه لانه اي
معلمه تحصل على اجازه امومه
الضمان الاجتماعي يتكفل بدفع رواتبها
كامله يعني
انا اتكلم عن الطلبه واتكلم عن انه حتى
عدد المدرسين من حيغطي الطلبه استاذي
استاذي استاذي الطلبه دائما التغذيه
الراجعه من اولياء الامور انه المعلمه
غايبه المعلمه ما اعطت حصص احنا كلهم
بيجيب معلمي هذا اللي بيحصل المدرسه
اجتهدت اجتهدت وكان اجتهادك خاطئ كان
اجتهاد خاطئ يجب ان تلتزم باختصار
بالتعليمات والاظم والتشريعات او على ذلك
لا ضرر على المدرسه لانه اي معلمه تحصل
على اجازه اميمه تتقاضى مخصصه الراتب من
الضمان الاجتماعي لذلك هنالك بدائل كثيره
هنالك بدائل كثيره بتعرف ان الفائض اكثر
يعني العرض اكثر من الطلب لذلك ممكن
المدرسه ان تحصل
وزاره التربيه والتعليم في الاردن هذا
سؤال تحديدا شو المنظومه شو يعني
الاجراءات المتبعه عاده عندما تاخذ مثلا
معلمه اجازه طويله للوضع او لغيره الا
يكون هناك بديل لهذه المعلمه معلمه وهذا
بيكون جزء من منظومه متكامله حتى لا يكون
هناك اي فراغ ولا يكون هناك اي نقص في
المعلمين
لانه هذه هي اصل المشكله هذا السؤال نحن
في القطاع الحكومي نحن في القطاع الحكومي
هناك التعيين على حساب التعليم الاضافي
بحيث يكون لهؤلاء المعلمين امتحان ثم
نصنفهم حسب الخبراتهم حسب الدور في
مديريات التربيه والتعليم وما ان تحصل
المعلمه على اجازه امومه مدتها ثلاثه اشهر
حتى يكون البديل جاهزا مباشره من اول يوم
تاخذ فيه المعلمه هذه الاجازه هذا
السيناريو هو المتبع في وزاره التربيه
والتعليم الاردنيه بحيث نغطي النقص من
خلال التعليم الاضافي وهناك في تخصصات
المعلمات يعني فائض في جميع التخصصات
ولهذا نحن في القطاع الحكومي ليس لدينا
مشكله في هذا الامر ايضا المدارس الخاصه
يجب ان يكون لديها خطه
بتعرفي الحمل ما بيجي في يوم وليله يعني
مجرد ما انه
المعلمه كانت يعني حامل يتوقع متى يعني
لحل المشكله قبل ان تقع المدرسه نعم
تستطيع المدرسه ان تضع خطه بديله لتامين
الصف بمعلمه اخرى
استاذ
منذر يبدو انه انتهى وقتنا مشاهدينا على
كل حال اشكر طبعا ضيوفنا اشكر منذر
الصوراني نقيب المدارس الخاصه في الاردن
وايضا احمد المعازفه الناطق باسم وزاره
التربيه الاردنيه شكرا جزيلا لكما لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات